[Music]
from the director of Shrek's you log
good good
keeping log and cut great work log
you're killing it today comes an eon so
musical based on a kid's toy that may
have ushered in the death of the
theatrical experience oopsies
troll - I mean trolls world sewer in a
world that's still stuck at home where
parents will snap it they have to watch
frozen - one more time a film will
bypass theaters entirely and buy them 90
minutes of peace as a team of writers
and directors with an average age of 52
serves up bright colors and poop jokes
for the little ones and now that's what
I call boomer megamix for the adults
[Applause]
return to the truly insane world of the
trolls movies where most objects have a
face and presumably a soul all the way
down to their bodily fluids everybody
has a serious case of ADHD is this some
kind of jewel it's actually kind of
cool-looking and your entire life is
determined by one of the six genres of
music techno funk classical country hard
rock and aren't there more than six
yarders shut up kids follow the heroic
journey of two pop trolls copy and
bridge she's the happy-go-lucky queen
with whatever the troll equivalent of
white privilege is you're not listening
to me you never listen to me branch what
are you talking about well he's more
unsure about troll cultural
appropriation which must have been tough
for Justin Timberlake to wrap his head
around together they'll try to stop the
evil queen of rock from destroying the
other genres and fail super hard at it
oh well have heartedly going through the
motions of a romantic B story with each
other you seem to make a good connection
must be tough to give it your all the
trolls don't even have genitals but wait
they do have parents but babies just pop
out of the dad's hair how many drugs
were they on when they made this
how many drugs with the characters on
[Music]
how many drugs are you on right now I'm
peachy
dance along to the main hook of the
trolls franchise license top 40 radio
one more time cuz sure you could go full
Disney and write an albums worth of
original classics or you could throw
some old hits in the microwave and press
lukewarm remix until money comes out but
to be fair there are a few original
compositions like the big finale
that proves when all genres of music
come together in one song it sounds
really planned and pleases nobody even
two genres at the same time is pushing
it that's how we got rap rock
[Music]
so enjoy this sugar-frosted take on the
age-old pop vs. rock debate even the
rock was pop for decades and today pop
is dominated by synchronized Korean girl
gangs or sand boys singing about the
prescription drug addictions but when
you need to throw something on to hold
your kids attention try the film that
probably would have came in winning
theaters but now might go down in
history as the reason you can't see fast
9 on the big screen next year oh man now
am I supposed to see my family star a
pop-tart Hidden Valley branch a Hoopoe
movie only James Corden just a fat
shamed James Corden mr. poopy butthole
guitar Shiro's Billy Clarkson we had to
find a thousand brown M&Ms to fill a
brandy glass Marazzi wouldn't voice--it
roll that night Hey
weird hair stuff
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh kids Bob
finding out your kingdom used to be evil
imperialists that's so hot right now
the conquest that built as gods empire
that goes against everything arendelle
stands for the path trolls started
snatching up all of the strings they're
eating her and then they're gonna eat me
oh my god
serenity now I'm a magical cat girl yah
yah yah there she was just walking down
the street singing dude why did he did
he dumb did he do